Let's move across the
Indian Ocean to the Maldives.
This is actually
the first story I ever did
for National Geographic
magazine in 2008.
And I met Guy Stevens.
He's a Manta ray researcher.
And he had discovered
what he reckoned was
the world's biggest manta
ray feeding aggregation
in the world, and...
the place was called Hanifaru,
and he had a major issue.
And the issue was the
fact that this site
was basically about to be
developed into a marina.
He asked me to be the
first person to photograph
his manta rays.
And basically, you know,
hopefully we were able to
use those images to try
to raise awareness
about this amazing,
amazing location there.
We had to travel in the
Southeast Monsoon.
Now this is not the
Maldives of your honeymoon.
It rains, it's dark,
the seas are very rough
for us to get out to the study
site using local boats.
The manta rays,
they love it
because what happens,
there's upwelling.
You know, a lot of nutrients
pushed to the surface
and you know, a lot of
plankton aggregate.
And these manta rays
migrate there
from all across the
Maldives mainly to feed.
Hanifaru Bay is
basically this
sort of, little island
on the bottom right
and then you have this, sort of,
weird indentation in the reef.
That indentation makes for
an incredible plankton trap.
And when the tides and the
currents are just right
all the plankton get
sucked into this bay
and it just gets
circulated in this eddy.
And it just increases and
increases and increases.
And this is where
the manta rays go.
Now when the
plankton concentrations
are quite patchy and low
the mantas,
they're solo artists
they feed by themselves.
Now, imagine you
are a manta ray
and the food is
quite patchy.
There's a patch there,
there's a patch there,
there's a patch everywhere.
Now, they can
either swim through
and feed on the
plankton like this
but then they have to go all
the way around to come back
and by that time the
patch might have moved.
So they do somersaults
backwards.
Like a puppy chasing
its own tail.
They just go around
because, I mean
that is the most effective
way for them to feed.
As the plankton
density increases,
they start to feed
cooperatively.
They create these
feeding trains
where one lines
up head to tail.
Now why do
they do that?
Well, plankton can't exactly
swim away from a manta ray.
But they can outmaneuver a ray.
So, the plankton can actually
feel the pressure wave
of the manta ray as it swims.
And they can leap
a few centimeters upwards
or downwards.
And they can leap over
the mouth of the ray
and then they tumble
down the back.
Of course now all they do is
they've tumbled into the
mouth of the next ray
or the next ray or the next ray.
So, it's an, you know,
a really efficient way to...
hunt down your food.
Plankton increases,
the water gets incredibly
cloudy and milky.
Hundreds of these guys
are aggregating now
and they're basically
coming together
for something that's
called "mass feeding".
Which is when multiple
of these feeding chains
kind of almost connect and
they create this sort of
crazy, in your face,
mass feeding ballet.
Free-diving here is
quite interesting.
You know, you have to be careful
not to get hit by these guys.
You know, they are completely
non-aggressive but they're big.
Three, three and half meters
or four meters of a wingspan.
And they can knock you out, but
most of the time it's a ballet.
You know where they are going
to be, they know where you are.
And then...
every year once in a while
something weird happens.
You know, these sort of ballet
dancers turn into drunks.
Bumper cars at a country fair,
it's just things go nuts
and they start crashing
into each other.
And something just goes horribly
wrong with the choreography
and you know, and that's
when you are in trouble
'cause you're
sitting underneath them
you're holding your breath
and you're going
"Oh, no!"
And then you have to
swim slalom-wise
to get through them
without them knocking you
on the head, which...
never been hit by a
manta ray, which is, you know
knock on, is this real wood?
( audience laughter )
Knock on wood. Great.
Manta rays, you know, when the
plankton's gone, they leave.
And there's a few enterprising
rays that have figured out
that plankton hides
on the seabed.
So they go down
on the bottom
and they scrape their
bellies on the seabed
and all the plankton
pops up out of the sand
and gets vacuumed up into
the manta ray's mouth.
So, you know, incredible
feeding behavior.
This was published
I think in 2008 or 2009.
And overnight, you know,
Hanifaru and its manta rays
were kinda teleported into
the offices and homes
of millions and
millions of people.
With the article, a lot of
grassroots conservation
movements on the ground
and you know, a very fortunate
change of government.
Hanifaru became a marine
reserve that same year.
And the President himself
actually vetoed the development.
So, today, you know,
Hanifaru is still
the place in the world for
tourists and divers to come
to actually observe this
fantastic manta ray aggregation.
And it's not a marina for
super-yachts, which is great.
In the Maldives, manta rays are
worth way more alive than dead
and I think they bring
in millions and millions
in tourism revenue,
every single year.
So as far as the conservation
of manta rays goes
the Maldives really are the
place to be these days.